did you have to audition for Superman
and Lois no you didn't
yeah you know I've talked to other
actors about this when you don't
audition it feels like oh look at me
like uh offer only but here's the
problem you never know if like they know
what they're getting they're like okay
this is what we want and you go on set
you start doing it and you're like oh no
no no we want something that's not what
we wanted you know that that could be a
little scary when you're not sure if you
audition like oh that's what they want
good I got it I know what I'm doing now
absolutely no questions asked no and
absolutely were you nervous first day
yes
terrified really oh my God but also too
you know I also the whole thing was so
strange to me like
um you know to your point is that I
didn't audition for this this came along
and you know I was thinking about this
in the car on the way up I thought if
this is going to come up or not and I
was like
I should start saying
I'll never
blah blah blah for the things that I
really want to do because I literally
was like I don't I've never I've I don't
think I've ever read a comic book I've
never watched I I don't watch superhero
things I don't like I know it's crazy
it's a little bit outrageous right and
so and this came along and my you know
my team called me like I started
laughing like I was like gosh that's
hilarious okay like as if and they're
like no no no really like
they the you know the creator of the
show would love to have a meeting with
you and I was like kind of [__] up
over it like I was like what
how
I don't even understand like I've never
ever worked on the CW before so what
would make them
have interest in me so a hundred percent
and like why me like I just not nothing
made sense I sat with Todd helbing
best decision I ever made in my life and
uh yeah the rest is history but the
funny part was that the last time I said
it's not like I'd ever do blah blah blah
was when I said about
um working with Adam Sandler like I
literally was like it's not like I'd
ever do an Adam Sandler movie
and then I didn't know how to say that
so maybe I should start doing